I was just kidding.
And then...
Sorry.
Oh, God.
I'm okay.
Oh, my bro.
Gochiti, ma'am, ojo-sama.
Hi, everybody.
Oh, gosh.
I'm getting over being sick.
So...
even though I'm a ghost um hello it's been a minute since I
last dreamed because I've been sick but um I'm here I'm here
oh my gosh I don't I'm ready but I'm so not ready I'm kind
of I'm so I'm not kind of scared I'm really scared I'm so
excited fatal frame 2 sick on vacation well actually this is
not a vacation for me i've been doing a lot of work well
supposed to are you on a different mic i'm actually i'm at
vicky's i'm at vicky's uh arcade so i'm on vicky's computer
at her arcade you guys the the dust i'm looking at on this
keyboard
I Sorry, sorry
Did you guys hear her?
She just comes up
I also I told her I was just like hey you know I'm borrowing
your arcade for for a bit so and I'm playing a really spooky
game so if you want to spook me even more I was like you
could bang on the door or something like scare me I'm not
scared actually I'm really scared you know uh fatal frame
fatal frame and i we go way back it's been so long since i
have played fatal frame 2 in general so i'm really really
excited and and you're scared but not but you are but i'm
not this is like the the you know how every game series has
like their game in the series that's like the game this is
the game this is this is the spookiest in my opinion it's
pretty spooky it's this well it is really spooky but um uh I
had a I had a friend she and I really love uh horror games
and we would watch horror movies together all the time and
we would play horror games together all the time and she she
and I um we would watch we would watch before they were like
translated you know like we were we were we we had like
somebody on youtube that was like real time explaining the
story that we were watching before the game came out over
here so we were we were very like super you know fatal frame
is is our jam and i always think my my whenever i think of
fatal frame i always think of her because of because of how
we would
she got so scared from this series that she had to get her
husband to hide the games in the closet for her because she
was just like if I see these games I start having like real
night terrors and stuff so yeah they're quite spooky they're
quite spooky I think.
But of course, we still love Fatal Frame to this day.
knocked away in a sacred tomb.
And, you know, for me, I know I'm kind of like gushing right
now, but I'm just so excited.
And for me, I own a lot of the games.
I don't think I have fatal frame 2 um uh xbox because they
did technically remake it then as well so this is like kind
of actually the third remake of fatal frame 2 um but the um
the fatal frame for the Wii U I bought that I bought the the
the European edition because they did not do a physical in
the United States so so I even though it's region locked I
still bought it so that I could have so that I could have a
physical copy of a fatal frame so yeah yeah yeah yeah fatal
frame or project zero well project it's called tech I guess
project zero in well it's like you're the UK call it project
zero right or you're calls it project zero and then uh in
japan it's also kind of i guess translated to project zero
so but yeah outside america but we're talking about fatal
fight today i mean it's all the same for the most part but
yeah yeah yeah yeah um the game i'm hitting all my points
the game is on steam That's how I'm playing it at the
moment.
Let me make sure my...
Oh, wait, one second.
Okay, I'm playing on Vicky's very cool, awesome Sonic the
Hedgehog controller, so he's going to help me rumble and
take perfect fatal frame photos all the time, every time.
But it's on Steam, and maybe if you're not so sure about it,
consider even Steam.
wishlisting it because uh you know sometimes even if a game
is out i still wishlist it you know to keep it in my uh in
my minds are in my in my thoughts um and you never know and
i'll go on title so yeah um but i you know i love fatal
frame so i've i'm of course gonna recommend it but i'm also
just excited to to check out this new remake i can't oh my
gosh i I can't believe we're here.
I was so, I was so like, is this series, you know, is it
going to be touched again?
And here we are.
I'm so, I really hope that this becomes like a Fatal Frame
Revival that we get, you know, more J-horror in general.
Oh, gosh, I'm so excited.
Yeah!
So, let's get into it.
we'll do oh for those who want to enjoy the story makes it
easier to survive but awards fewer photo points we'll do
normal let's battle wraiths are stronger scary scary uh for
those who don't know so you are not you have no guns you
have no swords you have no nothing you have you have your
cute little self and you have uh you have the camera
obscured which will instead of attacking you you are you are
taking photos of the ghost so honestly what makes it so much
scarier is your your field of vision becomes so narrow oh my
gosh the amount of times you'll like turn around and there
will be the ghost behind you think difficulty settings
can be changed at any time during the course of the game oh
my gosh okay nice sorry also if I'm coughing like I said I'm
I'm sick don't know don't take her selfie it's luckily it's
it's a special camera it's not it's not any camera maybe
Mayu didn't we always promise each other Oh!
That we would be together forever?
My you?
Oh, my controller be rumbling.
I'm sorry.
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh, it's beautiful!
We used to play here all the time.
It's so pretty!
Oh, all of this will be gone soon.
How's your leg?
Does it hurt?
These outfits are iconic.
Iconic J-horror protagonist.
Outfit.
It's so pretty.
Oh, my gosh.
Little baby.
Please, please!
Don't leave me!
Mayu, about what happened back then?
Duh-dun!
You saw it, the Crimson Butterfly!
No!
Don't go into the darkness!
Mayu!
How's the audio, everybody?
And everything.
I'm not on my usual setup, so...
Where are you going?
Things might be a little different than usual.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
My...
My... you...
Oh...
I'm walking.
My you...
Cute.
I'm walking Yes, thank you The game says Good job, gamer Oh
my gosh I'm wondering if I should I don't want to I don't
want to shut the curtains I'm scared I'm glad I'm playing
this In the daytime But also I can't see anything Because
it's Kind of a glare from the light.
Mayu!
Mayu, I'm going through the woods.
I'm just, I'm going in blind, baby.
Oh my gosh.
The way they run, it's just so iconic.
Oh, I didn't even press anything.
It did it on its own.
Okay, nice.
Atmosphere is great.
Right?
Bonk.
That's not suspicious.
I'm so sorry.
Caves so old, no one remembers the cutscenes.
There's just, there's the iconic one with the hand on the
shoulder.
But it's been a really long time since I last played this.
So honestly, I do feel like I'm playing it for the first
time again.
Oh, it's nothing.
Mayu?
Oh, they're so...
They're so...
They look so lost village.
They look so good.
You!
I'm so excited.
I'm scared.
Not excited.
The lost village.
Hold hands!
You guys, this might be the best game ever, no?
Don't let go.
And people who get lost in the woods are called to the
village.
do you think this is no take my hand let's go yeah let's go
oh my gosh so cute let's see creepy ritualistic stone we
don't we do not perceive don't worry about it I'm holding
your hand I'm not gonna let go I'll never let go
wow wait this is so nice We can have, we can, we can just
grab her.
Oh my gosh.
We're walking, we're walking through the woods.
It's dark.
Forgotten village.
For smarts and village.
I've, I've, oh.
Definitely.
I wonder if anyone's in there.
This is the dust scene.
Oh,
it's so iconic.
Oh, it's so iconic.
Guys, I think this place might be haunted.
There's someone in here though.
No, I don't think, you know, I definitely won't get
separated from you, right?
All right, let's go inside.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of how the ghosts will be.
What if they're too spooky?
Oh, we got something here.
News clippings.
A pair of clipped newspaper articles printed about a year
prior concerning search efforts to find Masumi Makimura.
A missing geological surveyor.
Oh.
Geological surveyor goes missing.
A 26-year-old surveyor by the name of Masumi Makimura has
gone missing.
after being dispatched to conduct work on the construction
site of the Minakami Dam.
The dam, which has been in the work since last year, is set
to submerge parts of the area underwater.
Makimura was sent to investigate the impact construction may
have on local historical sites and other areas of concern.
Vah has yet to return after five days.
one second sorry maybe i need some tissue
yeah search for missing survey are called off oh my gosh
what a strange name for a for a search off the search for
missing 26 year old geological surveyor masami makimura
which began on the fourth of this month was officially
called off yesterday off kid named off i was officially
called off yesterday after turning up no leads makimura who
had been missing for 10 days prior to the search's
cancellation was surveying the Minakami Dam construction
site.
What is that?
What does...
What is...
What is that?
What does that button mean?
Off yesterday, prequel to off today.
Huh, I don't have a touchpad on this controller.
or so let's see what we got oh there are items and
everything we're gonna get nice nice we're gonna get herbed
up baby uh files photo mode no way oh oh my gosh oh she
scared me what is it light number whoa you can like set the
lights and everything what wait this is so our spooky black
and white filter pastel oh gosh look this is like super
weathered page it's just smog black point teal and orange
there's so many oh wait this is this is this would be great
for like uh for like i don't know something silly filter
intense
wait it's so it's too goofy
there's so many what the heck what else is there we got
frames we got the fatal frames wait did they have one that's
like oh my gosh like the ui of the wait they're like yeah
just be silly with it honestly whoa cinema show copyright
funny and the date and everything wait that's so cute that's
so fun sorry i love photo modes oh so sorry about my cough
you guys this is why i haven't been streaming because i i
just actually it's probably today is like one of the best
that i've sounded uh in the past week so
No, actually, oh, can I take a cough medicine?
Sorry, one second, yeah.
I'll leave it.
It's nice and spooky, scary.
Maybe something will happen if I...
Sorry, don't ignore the chicken.
If you guys have ever taken medicine in Japan, it's very
funny because, you know, you can get, like, all...
encompassing medicines but a lot of them will be like
separated for sorry we cannot ignore this chicken but um oh
the medicines will be uh so this one is like a medicine
specifically for basically just cough um hanamisu uh drool
and if your throat hurts but you have to take three at a
time
I think the ghost of a chicken is haunting me Do you guys
hear that?
The ghost of the chicken
It's kind of scary I'm trying to take my medicine Oh oh my
gosh she just said it hurts wait oh now i can't tell what's
what's happening in the game what's happening
i uh there's multiple spirit this place is there's too many
spirits in this place yokai we have we have a you day yose
yokai all in the house
but yeah so i have to take three pills to sorry okay i'm not
stalling by the way i'm like so not scared I'm like not
stalling.
I don't have to take my medicine so I don't cough so much.
R2.
Oh.
We're going in.
Oh, we're not going in.
It's locked.
It's like getting Sokyo in there.
Oh my gosh.
It's like so much is coming back to me at the same time.
I guess no one's here Should we look around Me too
Woe visions Gosh it's so loud I'm gonna turn it down What
is this?
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, it's all coming back.
I don't want to kill anymore.
Oh, the grain just makes it so scary.
wait that looked amazing oh my god that looked amazing what
was that i don't know i don't know i think we're in trouble
might be a good time to leave
why are you laughing meinto because i'm excited The way she
like turns around and looks at her is so...
Mayu.
So cute!
Alright, come on.
I'm dragging.
Don't go too far.
What's over here?
No, don't worry, I'm not gonna let go of your hand.
Might be the only way I get through this.
So don't leave me.
You better not leave me.
You guys don't hear anything.
Also, I like that.
You guys are kind of covering it, but there's a little mini
map, which is pretty nice.
you guys don't hear that right we don't have a camera so
we're we're technically safe until we grab the camera wait
how do i get to the stairs here one thing about fatal frame
as well is um when you do get the camera ah there's like
secret ghosts and stuff too you always kind of want to be on
your toes to to get a photo um like you'll see like like
ghost will just kind of not only just ghosts that you have
to fight but also ghosts that will like just be wandering
around the hallways and stuff yeah secret spirits it's so
hard to see for me hopefully you guys actually if i look
through obs it's like it's easier um i can't open the door
because we're too busy holding hands it almost sounds like
someone's walking behind us
okay i think i hit oh wait there's another staircase here i
don't know where i'm walking i just am there we go it's so
stinking dark
it is dark this is scary we're investigating wait is this
not the hallway that we saw uh just now in the vision you
know whose steps were those I don't know.
Get out of here.
Wait.
It sounds like there's another pair of spots.
We should go very far in.
I agree.
Actually, one thing I want to see real quick.
What the?
Is...
If I go back into options...
Um...
Oh, so we can change the...
voice.
If you guys wanted
Nihongo.
Oh, wait.
Maybe we can't change it.
I guess you have to change it at the very beginning of the
game.
My bad.
I wanted to see, though.
Let's see.
Subtitles and stuff.
Outfits during movies.
Oh!
You can't wait!
Also, if you get, like, the DLC and stuff if you get like
the cute like bunny ears or whatever you can have it so that
they display in the cutscenes and stuff oh nice show area
name we have that on show okay I'm just looking around what
kind of controls and stuff we got the cat ears there was a
DLC for something hmm
but anyway okay take my hand i know we shouldn't go in but
we must progress the story despite probably everything that
would tell you otherwise to to not do the door is stuck all
right you circle around me
What is it stuck from?
Yeah, can we stay in the comfy hall?
I don't know if this is so comfy.
Do you think this is comfy?
Please enlighten me.
What do we find comfy about this?
Is it the drag stains on the wall?
Is it...
Well, at least this is lit.
It's lit.
There's a padlock engraved.
with a mjoga m...
m...
mjoga m...
mj...
on the door.
the m...
I can't say it.
No, no, no.
I'm trying to grab her hand.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Alright, so we got two doors.
One stuck.
Did we go down this way?
This is a wall.
Boy!
What was that?
Don't let go of my hand!
Please!
I think this is...
Okay, we just went into a big old circle, didn't we now?
Over here, I had heard a ghost.
wasn't me he's like you hear him he's all oh maybe can I go
through here
it's so
scary it's rats probably or something and that's me I'm the
rats actually I'm just look at that face I see a door
oh come on don't we go in here oh I don't see any oh there's
something on the ground here who's this what if someone else
is the battery still seem to work someone must have dropped
it ah i don't like that oh makes it easier to find items
like so
db it's so scary when it's slow like that
a notebook appearing to belong to a woman who wandered into
minakami village this desperate looking entry was written
rather hastily if anyone if anybody is reading this note
please come find me i don't care who it is just help me i
can't get out of this village save me miyako sudo um just
leave bozo i don't know just just get out of here just
Just...
Take the...
Take the road!
Wait!
Don't scare me!
Come on, Yu.
Come here.
Mayu, come here.
Mayu, what was that?
Mayu?
Oh my- No!
Stop it!
That's disgusting!
Me sleeping in the little fetal position every night.
oh a bed the bed okay women's notebook too appearing to a
woman who wandered into minakami village the entry discusses
the story surrounding minakami village which is said to have
vanished from maps
i remember hearing stories about a village that disappeared
from maps supposedly it was because on the day of big
festival a long time ago, tons of people got massacred.
But it still exists, and the twin Gizo statues that can be
found in the surrounding forest will lure lost people
towards it.
Once you pass through the gate at the entrance, there's no
leaving it.
From there, the night of the massacre continues, and the sun
never rises.
In the midst of all that, I can hear echoing throughout the
place.
As the stories go, the only survivor in the village that
night was, you guessed it, a lone woman.
Do you guys know that the first Fatal Frame game is
technically, as they say, based on a true story?
That's the first one though.
Why did that blink?
Together.
why is my flashlight blinking i don't like that why is my
flashlight blinking no i thought that was supposed to work
why is my flashlight blinking
okay now we have uh we have visibility this is great this is
a huge improvement i'm like gripping her i'm i was
the main entrance, no?
So maybe we go back...
Let's go through here.
Oh, this is the door I was trying to go through before, but
I couldn't see it.
Oh, I hear him.
Touch a butterfly lantern to save your progress.
Did you say what?
That's not a butterfly lantern.
I think we have to go inside to find the butterfly.
Wait.
Look.
The map has been updated.
Oh, look at that.
Okay, nice.
Oh, okay.
So we can, like, zoom in.
And it shows us our locks and everything.
Very nice.
Very standard.
Where is it?
Oh, here it is.
Sure.
Select it.
that's auto there we go we'll just save it anyway very nice
osaka house kimono room point exchange ah points that you
gain from taking pictures can be exchanged for items yes yes
yes the types of items available for trade will increase as
you progress through the game yes charms what's a scenery
charm the camera will focus on the entire shot when you
photograph gosh wait what's it it looks the same to me
what's different actually oh like the oh it's like a little
more modern looking oh that's so cute the red kimono yeah
very slight i thought i thought it looked the same so and we
got access accessories yes cat ears yes Yes!
Change outfits for the first time.
Alright, Mio, you get cat ears.
Mayu, you get cat ears.
Oh gosh, they're so cute.
Yes.
Oh, my little nyanyan, so cute.
Oh, we can't be scared now.
now.
Look how cute she is.
What is it?
Oh, no.
The Mjoga motif came.
Ew.
What the heck is that?
I wonder what that nasty thing is for.
Just creeping around in your room.
The map has been updated.
yeah you got a little bandage you okay you're all right come
here give me your hand yeah what's in here can we change
these batteries
you hear of oh this sounds terrifying oh that's that doesn't
look good well also looks kind of fresh turn around.
I've got some more stuff over here.
It's so scary.
Women's Notebook 3!
Sometimes I sense a figure walking past the window outside.
It's someone holding a torch whispering about something as
they walk along the road.
It sounds to me like they're looking somebody.
I don't know who it is, but I know it's not Masami.
I can also hear music off in the distance.
Mornful sounding music, like it's some sort of festival.
Wouldn't that be, if it's a festival, wouldn't it be so
exciting and fun and awesome and not sad, mournful music?
Oh yes, I love the festival of being sad and depressed.
Being upset.
Sad Matsuri.
Domingue, I missed you!
Thank you!
Depends on the motif.
It's my favorite time of the year, sadness festival.
They say this village disappeared on the night of a
festival.
A night that repeats over and over and over again.
Cool.
Sorry.
Let's go.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go, yeah.
All right, where was that?
Was it upstairs?
I feel like we're being watched by someone.
Where?
If you guys see a ghost, that's not me.
yell um okay how did I get up there again the stairs right I
said not me I said not me close to bottom right not me oh
wait I forgot there was a wait did I go in here or was this
closed oh no it's stuck yeah come here come on Come here.
Give me your hand.
No, give me your hand.
Oh, there's something shiny over there.
Definitely hear things behind me sometimes.
I went down, there was like a hallway.
I did make a loop.
I can't remember now.
Sorry.
I'm also still kind of waking up.
So, I hope you guys don't mind.
I'm still sleepy.
From where I am haunting and Vicky's arcade is quite far, so
I had to get up a little later.
Good morning, Minto!
Yeah.
Yeah, I am Eepy!
I want to see if that triggers her.
Their clothes are so cute, no?
It's a bit cold.
the atmosphere is too good
no camera obscura memo oh no our time of safety is almost to
an end everybody a memo found in the Osaka house's altar
room outlining the functionality of the camera obscura the
camera obscura is a photographic device designed by Dr.
Kunihiko Aso to capture spiritual beings that are typically
imperceptible to the human eye.
Specifically, it is capable of revealing the following.
Past events as contained in residual emotional energy.
Invisible apparitions.
Though I am certain it can capture even more than that.
Photographing these supernatural phenomena that defy
conventional thought enables the wielder to achieve an
effect akin to a traditional exercise.
some gross why would you guys do that however this process
also establishes a bond with the subject as a result
judicious use of the camera obscura is required otherwise
these operations may take over the user yeah you'll i forgot
to say too you get like different types of film and stuff
like you get stronger films and um so uh it's and and and
it's it's like bullets where they're limited amounts so uh
you do kind of have to play you have to take your shots well
one can only imagine what this gadget can unearth if one
were to photograph the hidden ceremony that takes place in
minakami village as well as the locations that are central
to the residents I believe I can speak for myself and the
good doctor when I say that the possibilities intrigue me.
I have a camera.
But you probably haven't heard of it.
It's pretty obscure.
Yeah.
I'm not even...
I'm just not in your eyes, girl.
No.
no golly okay here we go everybody
no don't yeah i agree don't do it this is it the device to
capture the impossible the camera obscura
there is a not fatal frame game for the 3ds that uses like
your actual
yet oh my gosh we're getting hugged today i crave the touch
believe it so it's true then
this is an extremely dangerous device now it's over for us
guys it's over i'm touched though i came off scara mia what
is that The cat ears are...
They're cat ears.
Yeah.
I'm cosplaying, yeah.
Camera obscura.
A camera that was left behind in the village.
It can photograph things.
The eye cannot see.
We're going to take pictures of our cosplaying now, yeah.
Several printed photographs showing parts of the village.
Were they taken with this camera?
Type 07 film Old film for the camera obscura There's plenty
remaining It's in bad shape But still usable
Shooting photographs Raise the camera obscura Okay, L2 Shoot
with R2
The camera's focus will gradually adjust As you keep the
target in view That's one thing So to try and get the fatal
frame.
The, like, not the 07 film.
07, you guys.
07.
Wait a second real quick.
Um, to try and get the fatal frame, you have to like really,
like, there's like a meter that will like fill up like a
gauge and you like keep it on the ghost for as long as
possible.
Where the heck?
Hold on, one second.
Uh, uh, uh, yeah.
Yep.
Where's my mouse?
I'm lost in the sauce right now.
There we go.
Okay.
Um.
Once you've taken a picture, you'll need to wait for the
photo charge to complete before you can shoot another
photograph.
Controls can be changed under option.
Oh, okay, nice.
Viewing photographs, pictures that you've taken can be
viewed and managed from the menu screen.
Okay.
that camera still works oh no look how cute she is though
of course right of course the one picture i took is she
blinks girl come on
ray's camera controls wait what is that
um but yeah the the the film that they give you the i guess
i don't not the cheapest how do you say The weakest, the
weakest one is infinite.
I'm blocking it with my head, but it is infinite.
But then you get the stronger ones, like you find them and
you buy them and stuff.
Low grade.
Yeah, yeah.
The photo management screen can be used to check the photos
that you've taken.
Photos are automatically saved to temporary storage.
Once the temporary storage is filled, the oldest photos will
be erased to make space for new ones.
You can move photos to permanent storage in order to keep
them from being erased.
automatically okay oh my gosh i can't believe she blinked
i can't believe she blinked uh messed up all right let's go
do our first fight i suppose i'm scared
oh so scary
oh that
was so creepy ew her face
oh my god too scary get away from me please
there we go that should do it
ew wait i want to see my photos now but the camera obscura
rays the light at the top of the camera obscura indicates
the direction of the spirit so you can photograph will turn
red.
Look around.
R with camera.
Yeah, so this is what I mean.
You can find other ghosts and stuff too.
Quickly look around.
L3 plus R.
Oh.
Okay.
Flashbang to death.
Yeah, well, actually, to double death.
While exploring, while you do not have the camera obscure a
race, there is an indicator displayed on the edge of the
screen.
However, this indicator is not displayed for race that you
haven't discovered yet.
Wait, what?
I like how you can play it.
Ta-ta-ta-ta!
Spooky little ghost lady.
You can fight back against wraiths by taking pictures of
them with the camera obscura.
You can repel a wraith by lowering its HP.
Indicated at the top of the camera obscura display.
Yeah, so actually, that was kind of nice.
It showed like how much damage your photo will do.
So that was kind of nice.
I could tell when I was about to kill her.
Seven months of Minto obsession.
Thank you!
Very spiffy.
The higher quality of photograph is, the more damage it will
deal.
Keys to good photographs.
Correct focus.
Multiple key elements in frame.
The preview of the damage max is so good.
Yeah!
Yeah, that's so handy.
As you keep a target in frame, the camera obscura will
gradually bring it into focus.
You can unlock the ability to adjust the camera obscura's
focus manually through upgrades.
You can also lock on to a wraith to automatically keep it in
frame.
However, lock on is released when a wraith vanishes.
Okay, so R3, lock on.
Oh my goodness.
You will be downed if you are attacked by a wraith.
you have no willpower.
Willpower is depleted through the following actions.
Being hit by attacks, touching wraiths, running during
combat, and evading.
That's so messed up.
I can't even be a baby.
I can't even run.
Oh, I'm glad you've been enjoying Portal.
Thank you.
Willpower is restored through the following actions.
Photographing wraiths, passing time.
using lunar incense.
Um, one second.
I want to see my photos.
Wow.
So artistic.
Ew.
That one's gross.
That one's so...
So scary.
The wanderer.
Ew.
What's the sub-menu?
Oh, if I want to save them and stuff.
Why are your hands like that?
Yeah, this one is a good one.
No, it's really creepy.
Standing manomoy.
All right, let's go help.
I'm running.
Come here!
Mayu!
Are you okay?
Let's just get out of here.
Agreed.
Leave the house.
Such a good idea.
Yeah.
Any other items in here?
So yeah, you'll kind of like...
Imagine if something like popped out of there, no?
Sorry.
I don't like when they open the door so slowly.
Oh, that ain't good.
That's not good.
Wait, special shot?
Oh, just kidding.
Wait, oh, R1.
special shot okay good to know are you here okay good no
don't worry about it hold my use hand to recover health hand
holding saves lives hand protecting my you i wish i could
read the descriptions but sorry guys i don't think my
controller has the option um was it this way
this seems like the exit now Right here.
Yeah, let's get out of here, guys.
No way!
It's still shut.
Over there.
Woman roaming the second floor.
Ew!
Follow the woman's shadow.
No.
Come here.
Where was the...
Oh, that's fine.
Um, so let's go upstairs.
I'm scared.
I'm scared too.
Where should I go into this room?
Oh!
Oh, it's her diary.
She's still writing.
And then even an after.
Women's notebook five.
A notebook appearing to belong to a woman who wandered into
a Minakami village.
this entry sees the author lamenting her inability to leave
she's still complaining about that how long have i been in
this village now i have no idea the sun never rises here
it's always night i hate the dark now i can feel it driving
me insane i want to leave
one second Oh my gosh.
Oh, I want to see Masumi.
Please, please.
Yeah, she's only there for like 20 minutes.
She's so dramatic.
All right, let's go in.
This was stuck early.
remember?
Come on, grab my wing.
Grab my wing here.
I'm scared.
Yeah, grab my wing.
Something's not right about this place.
Beckoning woman.
Oh, I love a beckoning woman.
Yeah, something, you're just now noticing something not
quite right about here?
I think I realized from a long time ago.
I think I...
What are you looking at?
Stop it.
Oh, is that film?
Oh.
Oh, it's medicine!
Additional peels.
Consume to restore health.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh!
What?
How do I see my health, though?
I think I'm blown.
blocking it, but I'm, I think I'm max.
I think we're okay.
Peel's here.
Was there anything else?
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Come here.
The way she like so dramatically runs behind me.
It's too cute.
Ew.
The atmosphere is so scary.
Stone mirror.
A stone that gives off a strange light.
When you're healthy, reach a zero it will take your place in
death one time nice come here take my head together together
yeah yeah together oh she's still writing you guys ready to
get ambushed
ew woman's notebook nine i think we missed a few wait Well,
last one was five, no?
The text of this final entry is abruptly written in parts.
I can't move anymore.
I'll just stay here.
I know Masumi will come back for me.
It's a six upside down.
He just needs to find a way out of the village first.
If Masumi comes back for me, I'm going.
I'm going.
he came back oh so scary
scary okay time to fight mastermind oh so she
got lost in this place too yeah she came in here looking for
her boyfriend and then where did she go this place must be
why you stop reading my diary my why all right
let's fight
Oh my god.
Ew, what a creepy photo.
There we go.
Come on, focus.
The fatal frame.
Oh, thank you, I just missed it.
Oh, that did like nothing.
There we go, nice, nice.
Oh yeah, let's lock on, that's true.
I forgot about that.
Oh.
Block on.
Oh, dang it.
I tried pressing it.
Dang it!
So scary!
No!
Get him over, babe!
Yeah!
Ooh, that one was creepy.
Oh.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Nice!
Once you've inflicted a sufficient amount of damage on the
race, it will become defenseless.
I'm not turning it down this way.
Is that turning it down for you guys, too?
Well, what I was adjusting was making it lower for you guys,
but it was just making it lower in my ears.
There we go.
That should be a bit better.
I think the game
is...
Maybe more like that.
It's a bit better.
Okay.
Once you've inflicted a sufficient amount of damage on a
wraith, it will become defenseless activating a Shutter
Chance.
Shoot a photo with a wraith in this state.
Significant damage.
The wraith will return to normal once you've taken a
picture.
Furthermore, successfully taking a fatal frame while a
wraith is vulnerable to shudder chance will activate fatal
time giving you an opportunity to take multiple photos and
quick succession pictures taken during fatal time will
automatically use type 07 film thanks guys for all my gifts
thank you so much thank you for all the oh the oh the oh the
oh the gift and membership thank you still a bit loud when i
ask you guys are earlier he said it wasn't so loud maybe
like that sorry like I said I'm not at my usual setup so I
can't really tell so easily but thanks for being patient
with me this part is just loud yeah I kind of oh oh evading
and shaking off if you fail to stagger a race with fatal
frame it will attack or grab hold of you you can evade the
evade is okay I don't think it's the X that I'm using.
Okay.
Run L3.
Oh, look.
Ooh, that one was kind of creepy looking.
And...
Ew, ew, ew!
Get off of me.
My willpower is depleting.
She looks so silly in that one.
Ew, that one was creepy.
Oh, I did the special shot that time.
I wanted to try it.
Okay, and we're almost to that significant damage.
Come on, turn around, lady.
Oh, my God.
She's just trying to give me a hug, no?
I'm in
the cabin.
Crimson butterfly.
Good morning, Minto.
Oh, dun-dun-dun.
We're on Chapter 2!
The Twin Maidens.
Oh, I love twins.
Oh, no.
Oh, Mayu.
You were supposed to always stick with me.
Why?
Mayu.
Mayu!
Psst, pst, pst, pst, pst, pst.
Wait, what's my...
Oh, my health is back to normal.
too, so I should...
Eww.
Oh.
Oh!
It's something spooky.
Wait.
Does it restore its health, though?
Oh, it does, though.
Hmm.
Maybe we need something even stronger for opening that.
Interesting.
I do like the camera Oh.
Never mind.
I don't like when the camera or when the with the flashlight
shutters.
I don't like it at all I don't like it at all actually.
I think I changed my mind
I think I changed my mind.
I don't like it.
Let's just uh Spirit Stone Radio.
You're listening to Spirit Stone Radio.
And while it's radio for Spirit Stone, sometimes you can
hear a mysterious voice emanating from it.
Spirit Stone Radio Memo.
Oh, Rocky!
Thank you so much for the red!
Hello!
Welcome, welcome.
Hi, Rito.
Hello!
We're checking out Fatal Frame today.
And it's very spooky.
I'm scared.
No, I'm not.
I'm not scared.
I'm totally fine.
I'm normal.
Everything's fine.
Everything's... Everything's adorable.
A memo outlining the functionality of the Spirit Stone
Radio.
by the same person who invented the camera obscura.
Spirit Stone Radio?
Memo.
The Spirit Stone Radio takes the basic concept of a crystal
radio which uses crystals in part of its circuitry to pick
up signals and upgrades it to enable voices to be heard from
the spirit realm.
It's basically a spirit box.
Yeah, I'm so normal.
Yeah, I'm not scared by other ghosts.
I'm not scared by other ghosts.
these voices come from crystals and other such materials
that were previously worn by people for extended periods of
time oh imagine the smell after prolonged contact the
owner's emotions become embedded in these rocks releasing a
special kind of light invisible to humans such stones are
referred to as spirit stones according to dr kunihiko aso
sounds emitted from the spiritual realm can sometimes be
heard without the aid of a radio hello my nose is all stuffy
premonitions the ability to sense others and synchronicity
similar to those found in twins are all things
attributable attributable to these sounds bless you thank
you it is nice I feel like snowsing sneezing I feel I feel
like snow's in.
Mayu's charm.
It's the charm that Mayu is wearing.
Perhaps it holds her thoughts.
I'm snowing.
Equipping charms confers their blessings upon you.
A charm bag will increase...
The number of charms you can equip.
My sister.
Uh-oh.
She don't want it anymore?
How do I equip it now?
Oh, here we go.
My use charm.
Health recovers faster while holding hands.
Decreases health damage taken from wraiths.
Oh, extends fatal time window.
Increases the chance of encountering certain wraiths.
I don't like...
I don't want any increased chance of encountering one
wraith.
Okay.
Spirit charm Reduces willpower consumption when dodging and
running I can only equip one at a time Maybe we'll do Mayu
Decreases health damage taken from wraiths That's pretty
good What time is it?
It's fatal time Oh wait Mayu's charm
I don't know why Wow
If it's calling, you better pick up.
And then we have all of our items as well.
And it...
Oh, oh, I forgot we picked up these photos earlier, right?
Photograph labeled Ukishima on the back.
It shows a small island.
floating in a pond and a bridge leading to it how mysterious
yeah these are what we picked up when we first got the
camera obscura photograph labeled deep path entrance on the
back it appears to be a place called a kadol showing a
ladder leading deep underground yeah mayo's fine mayo's okay
and then we saw this one the umbral mound
Kayano Shows a box placed alone in a corner We got the West
Misono Hill Shows a large hollow in a tree Big enough for a
person to enter The garden veranda The deep path There's a
lot of photos
store room sliding screen room nice where are we now where
did I come from I came from oh this no not wait yes no oh
yes yes
The door opening.
I'll never get used to it.
That's so scary.
What was that?
My sister, my sister.
I'm sorry.
I have to go.
No, I need to hold your hand to restore health.
Leave the house.
Okay.
Easier said than done.
maybe you oh uh is there some like this way is there
somebody here oh did i miss it dang it oh i missed the ghost
in here see this is what i mean though when i said earlier
you kind of got to be like you got to be quick sometimes to
get to get the photo but the direction at the top is so nice
wait it's so nice okay how do i oh okay I think I see it.
Yeah, because sometimes there will be little ghosts hidden
around, like, and things like this.
And also, the fact that your flashlight flickers when it
happens, I don't like it, but I like it at the same time.
It's scary, and also great.
It's scary, and also helpful.
Oh, no.
Type O-O film.
Film marked with a special...
symbol it is a highly extremely high exorcism power but
takes a while to reload
oh no switching film while raised okay we only have the one
so obviously i'm not gonna
okay yeah look at the little spirits uh Ew, they look like
you guys.
They're kind of cute.
Ew.
Um, something's in there.
But we're going to try and leave.
My
flashlight keeps flashing.
Oh my god!
That's a bad guy.
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Oh, gross.
Oh, ew, I see his bones and stuff.
Blah.
Where'd he go?
Oh, that's a nice one.
And disgusting.
And I'm stuck.
Wherever I am.
I'm in the corner.
Look at him.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Ew,
that was so scary!
Ew, my willpower is nearly gone!
Nice!
Oh,
oh, that's scary!
There he is.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
He's so creepy.
Let's just get that right quick.
What?
His noises, I don't like him at all.
Where'd he go?
Wait, where'd he go?
This way?
It's a stressful game, I know, right?
Oh, it is so creepy.
So, so creepy.
Can he get in focus, please?
Becky!
Oh,
there he is.
Vicky tried to scare me.
Vicky did scare me.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, bozo.
Yeah!
Ha ha ha!
Holy girl!
Fee!
We're leaving.
I love...
I love running and immediately running out of breath.
It's so great.
What was this?
Type 14 film.
Old film.
It has low exorcism power.
and takes a while to reload.
Is there anything in here?
Anybody?
Or anyone?
Oh, well, well.
I'm leaving this place.
Ew!
Grandpa.
Man peering into camera obscure.
Oh, he's looking at me.
He's gone.
There's something on the ground.
Oh.
Paraseptual Filter Memo.
A memo outlining the functionality of the camera obscures
paraseptual filter.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I need a second.
Between that fight and then...
And then Vicky opening the door.
Also, not me also jumping at Vicky's jump scares even though
I know they're coming.
I need a second.
Dang, that she got me good.
She got me good.
the camera obscura captures past events including their
residual emotional energy while testing its powers i
discovered an ingenious hidden feature by switching to the
paraceptual filter and photographing such residual energy
the resulting shadow recreates the past let's call these
shadows vanishing traces as in traces of memories in all
likelihood following these vanishing for missing people why
why then would doctor also conceal such tantalizing
functionality could it be that it remains incomplete or
maybe he thought approaching the spiritual realm in such a
matter was dangerous whatever the case may be sorry I know I
keep like clearing my throat and sniffling and everything
I'm a little sick you guys though I'm still getting over it
Whatever the case may be, I intend to use every tool at my
disposal to photograph places and things that aren't meant
to be seen.
Oh, I keep getting my buttons wrong.
A filter for viewing spirits, which filters with square when
the camera obscura is raised.
Yeah, look at that guy.
Yeah, you missed.
properties range long power average charging slow willpower
recovery low special ability allows you to see spirits
through walls up unlocked through upgrades blinding special
shot renders wraiths unable to see for a period of time
remove once photograph again consume 75% of willpower but
doesn't use film oh my goodness there's so many you guys
like tutorials.
The Perseptual filter allows you to see vanishing traces.
Could we see Minto through walls then?
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
I need my privacy.
I need my privacy too.
When you see traces of the past, raise the camera obscure
and switch to the Perseptual filter in order to follow them.
I
didn't find my sister.
Oh.
my sister oh wait wait i want a picture of you i forgot to
actually take i forgot to take the actual picture capture
traces of paris did i get it no it's kind of cool though oh
i wonder if that one works no okay okay okay Anything over
here?
That's where we came from.
Is there something here?
Wondering the village!
Please.
Grab.
Oh, gosh.
Don't...
Oh, get off of me.
I knew that was going to happen.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
Oh, geez.
Oh, that was a terrible one.
I knew it was going to happen.
Where is he?
Come on.
Oh, gosh.
The noises are so scary.
Dang it, I just missed it.
Come here, come here.
Attack me, big good.
guy attack me big guy i'm scared i'm scared nice
i know this guy is like annoying no oh my gosh it's so scary
oh when he does that i don't like it at all it's so scary
holy cow my willpower goes to nothing I just need to take a
photo.
So I can get some back.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on.
You so...
Eeky!
Please, please.
I can't move.
I don't know where I am.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Big, big score.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
Where'd he go?
Oh, he's in the woods.
So am I.
Oh, dang it.
I think I missed it.
That's okay.
Maybe I'll switch the film.
Well, I don't want to switch it just yet.
That one was so creepy.
You are a tough guy, man.
Oh, my finger slipped.
My finger slipped.
Where'd he go?
Wait, where is...
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Please, please, please.
Big damage.
Uh-oh.
Shake her, shake her, shake, shake, shake.
He threw me back inside.
This guy, man.
Get me on!
Get off of me!
I think he's behind me.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh, oh.
Oh my gosh, so close to...
Oh, oh, come on.
Guy.
So close!
Oh, my thing is still recharging.
Let's just get rid of him.
Yeah, annoying!
You're so annoying!
Is my health so bad?
It's like halfway-ish.
But the...
The heartbeat is scary.
Right?
I guess I'll use it.
Okay.
Just to get rid of the heartbeat sound.
Can I grab that now?
Thank you.
Oh.
That guy was such a lame.
I only have eight left, but I'll keep it on there.
hmm lots of stuff don't don't grab me oh more film nice what
do you mean are these ghosts accurate they're ghosts yeah
they're good no no no no lunar incense use it temporary wait
using it temporarily increases the regeneration speed of
willpower.
Very cool.
What was a...
That way.
My sister!
It's not a save.
Lantern.
Save.
Oh.
You.
By the creepy doll.
Twin doll findings!
written remarks from a folklore scholar who came to study
minakami village talking about his research on the village's
ubiquitous ubiquitous is that right twin dolls i've noticed
while trekking through minakami village that these curious
white dolls can be found adorning various locations i nailed
it The local residents refer to them quite simply as twin
dolls, derived from the fact that they come in pairs bound
together by a crimson thread.
The practice of decorating spaces with dolls can be found
all throughout Japan.
Wow, the very Sukoi-Nihon tradition of doll decorating.
Yes, I know.
Many of them are placed for purposes such as warding off
misfortune.
or to ensure that children grow up well.
So, Dessonet.
In the case of Minakami Village, these twin dolls appear to
function as guardian deities for the former use case,
keeping calamities at bay.
Although by design, these dolls are supposed to come in
pairs.
I've seen some cases of them appearing, quote-unquote,
alone.
It's something of a mischievous pastime among the village
children to snatch one of these twin dolls and hide it
somewhere.
Oh my gosh, the children are bringing in the calamities.
He would know.
When he tried to do the same thing during his previous
visit, he got scolded.
A fact he admitted to with no small amount of sheepishness.
Anyway, the twin dolls themselves are believed to hold the
thoughts and feelings of the sacrificial twin maidens.
Separating them is believed to invite men.
misfortune.
Yet children being who they are, the fact that it's
forbidden is likely precisely why they've turned it into a
game.
These darn kids.
There are pairs of no of dolls known as twin dolls hidden
throughout Minakami Village.
Memorializing twin dolls.
When you take a picture of a pair of twin dolls together,
you'll memorialize the feelings embedded within them.
Doing so will unlock the items at the point exchange.
Find missing dolls.
If a doll is missing his twin, try searching for it by
taking pictures with a paraceptual filter.
Remember there was the one that I was like, oh my gosh, it's
by itself.
Poor little baby.
Uh, I don't remember if it said it uses a film or not in
this filter, but whatever.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
Let's save.
Why not a save point?
You can open the point exchange.
Very cool.
New items have been added.
Let's go.
Good luck.
I'm in.
Thanks for all you do for us.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think if I'll be able to stream again before.
for the next portal come out i think maybe one stream and
then i have a few more portal playthroughs um sorry that i
haven't been able to stream so much though just because of
how sick i've been let's see what we got in the point
exchange we got some herbal medicine how much i have 17,000
spooky points spooky camera obscure points the blinding
charm increases blind effect duration blinding charm soup
soup good soup spooky the balloons they're my spooky the
balloons paraseptual charm increases the damage dealt by the
paraseptual filter wait a second oh no no I thought I
thought wait it does it does damage my brain ew spirit hand
oh it's a sticker oh good we can include we can oh when we
do photo mode we can we can put the very creepy spirit hand
four on top of on top of meo or my you i guess oh yes wow
what other spooky hands can we can we get That's so
exciting.
Mayu, you need to come back so we can see.
I equipped the cat ears to you.
We need them.
We need you back so we can see them, please.
Alright, nice.
There was a thing right here.
Oh, wait, let's look up our...
Oh, there she goes.
Hobbling down the stairs.
Bye.
Oh.
That looks fresh, too, no.
Type 90, film.
Film marked with a purifying symbol.
It has high exorcism power and a short reload time.
Let's go.
Am I starting to lag?
Oh, I think it just happens sometimes.
Yeah.
Following.
No?
Okay, cool.
What was that?
Dun dun!
Open the gate.
Mayu, my stupid sister, why are you following?
Why are you listening to them?
Huh?
Why?
Open the gate, huh?
Okay, knock.
knock i'm too weak each door of the gate features a twin
motif ornament they both have slots for inserting a wide
flat key do we have to find the twin jit crimson butterfly
crimson butter beckoning crimson butterfly Oh,
you're evil.
Let's try our new 90s.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
Ew, he regenerates.
I don't like that.
Oh, my God.
This lock.
god yeah dang it's not doing oh holy cow this guy this guy's
scary
oh oh dang it i'm stupid oh my god where is he oh my god i
just took one i panicked Oh my god, he's running.
Oh,
that was a good one.
Good job, Jim.
Get rid of this guy.
I pretty much used up all my film, but that's okay.
where should i go it's so disorienting once you're done to
like you know i have one left honestly though it's kind of
worth it for that guy
wait am i going the right way wait was this the way i went
wait where did butterfly go butterfly i'm lost butterfly in
the sky i need to tell me where to go
Butterfly?
Where's the butterfly go?
Oh!
Who's that?
Woman looking down.
Ew.
I went the wrong way.
Ew, ew, ew, ew.
That was so creepy!
Oh, there it is, yeah.
glowing butterfly she
beckons I can't tell if it's like if it's a butterfly that
is you know or oh my gosh wait was I just on the different
film I just right noticed that's okay though hello where are
you taking me I already went to this house it's scary
We're following.
We're running.
Actually, did we go this way?
Maybe.
Not?
Not this way.
Yeah, this is new territory.
Why is the key all the way over here anyway, Vaughan
Butterfly?
You're taking me- Ooh!
Audible Medicine.
Love to see it.
Oh!
Seeing if there's anything around here.
The grain makes it so...
I always thought, like, the grain on the camera always made
it so freaky, you know?
Okay.
Dun-dun!
Oh!
No,
I'm Minto.
Who are you?
Who are you, Nya?
Did they find me, Nya?
They will guide me.
Find...
There's a lot going on in here.
Oh.
No!
My stone mirror is full.
I forgot.
Wait.
I wonder if that activates automatically.
No, just a...
Because it will...
It's active.
Wait.
Let me get your picture, buddy.
Oh, you're so bright.
How do I turn off my...
Look at you.
Oh.
Say.
Cheese.
Trapped boy.
Can you...
Actually, can you stop whispering?
I can't hear you.
The gate closes once the twins have been gathered.
The keys to the gate are hidden somewhere.
But I'm the other twin.
Cheese.
Yai, follow the Crimson Butterflies.
They will guide you.
My boys.
So soft-spoken.
Oh, there's two!
It did say, didn't it, like, follow one out of two or
whatever?
Also, the crouch, it keeps telling me to, like, crouch, but
it does it automatically, which is kind of nice.
Prayer beads!
A jewel infused with someone's will inserted into the camera
obscura to enhance performance.
The camera obscura and its filters can be upgraded through
the use of prayer beads.
You should do ASMR.
You should.
You can't hear him?
That's why we have subtitles, luckily.
I could barely hear him, too.
Reversion beads can be used to reset upgrades.
I'm too short.
Ew, this is such an icky area.
Oh, oh, well.
I might have gotten it.
Playing girl!
It looks like a whole bunch of wheat to me.
Yes, that's definitely...
Imagine taking that photo to like, you know, the places that
are like, whoa, we will buy your ghost photography.
Imagine taking that photo there and be like, I promise you
there's a ghost in that photo.
I really...
I'm serious.
There's a ghost in that one.
I can guarantee.
you have my my scouts on her where'd he go oh
yeah one second I've got to be it real quick
okay sorry about that hello oh why is there a save here hmm
Okay.
Is there anything?
Alright.
I'm following the butterfly.
This would be a really beautiful place, no?
If, uh, if we weren't so dang cursed, maybe.
Hey, look.
We got it.
Hmm.
Oh.
Oh, I found some film here.
Oh, I didn't even notice it was down here.
Nice.
We got little piles of rock.
Can I knock this over?
Yeah, stupid kids.
We got lots of rocks.
Actually, lots of piles of rocks.
Guiding Crimson Butterfly.
knock this one over too
I'm missing my Easter who was the real monsters couldn't be
me where are you taking me butterfly oh wait I forgot I have
a flashlight I turned it off to take a picture of that guy
oh oh
I don't want to waste it, you know?
This one takes so long to float.
Yeah.
How good of a photo do I need it to be?
Like the bestest ever?
That's okay.
Oh.
Hmm.
in you oh it's so oh the the limited field of vision is too
much it's too scary
what's this oh open up i'm pillaging i like the shining uh
you cannot carry any more items my inventory is full
fulfilled no sinking away okay we gotta use up more of that,
I guess.
I got some prayer beads.
I wonder if I have to upgrade it.
Let's see.
Do it.
New...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder if I can just upgrade it now.
Ah!
Yes!
Okay.
Focus.
Focus the camera manually.
I don't know if I... I think I would forget.
We can zoom.
film capacity okay so that's what we need upgrade special
shot willpower recovery range it's so fun how like oh here
we go is the clairvoyance to see behind um how it's like you
know you're you're limited in this game to just having the
camera but uh you can upgrade it to like you know your
preferred style okay maybe we will do this one though
perceive spirits behind walls let's try it enhance the
filter for the first time cool i
see it no spirits behind walls wait where did actually the
where did our butterfly go Unless, this is where maybe the
key is?
Moonstone!
Moonstone that emits a pale white light contains the
thoughts of the woman who was hiding.
Ew, the woman that was hiding in the box!
Ew!
Ew.
I don't know if I like that.
Oh my god, the voice actress is going crazy here!
Eee!
Oh my god, so scary.
Too spooky for me.
Too spooky!
How am I gonna sleep tonight?
Sends window for performing a dodge.
Reduces amount of willpower needed for special shots.
Hmm.
There we go.
Yeah, I have the whole day to figure out how I'll...
i have the whole day to figure it out i like how you can
have 420 prayer bees that's crazy that's so many two out of
two we need more 90 film oh my god i
actually she just hear what she said
she looks she looked more scared than i was fear in her eyes
saying that what did she say she said six seven she jumped
scared me in like every every way that i could be jump
scared
let's see let's find our butterfly wait did i look in here
oh we're opening the box okay here we go
Spooky lady Spooky lady
No Greasy hands Madam Oh my god Oh no Oh my god That picture
was crazy Oh shoot Ouch oh my gosh Face for Ah extra damage
Oh my god Oh my god, getting hers.
Lady, please!
Holy cow.
I need to heal.
Wait, I need to heal.
Oh.
Scary, scary, scary.
I'll just take it anyway.
Please, please, load, please, load, please, load, please.
Oh,
I thought she just knocked.
knocked me outside.
That was crazy.
Ew.
Oh my God, she's so icky.
She's so icky.
I'm stuck.
Special shot.
But I have no willpower.
I have no willpower.
I wonder.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no, no, no.
Stand, stand, stand, stand.
That one was creepy too.
Oh my gosh, my health.
Oh, this game is so stressful.
Where is she?
There she is.
Oh, whoa.
So cool.
Oh, that wasn't my best.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Madam.
Oh, my God.
I keep forgetting to stand up.
It is all about timing.
This game is like, it's almost like a rhythm game, for real.
I wonder if I can...
Oh, Nandi.
Get, like, a good one with...
Oh, my God.
It's too scary.
Come on.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, why'd she turn red?
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, where'd she go?
Where'd she go?
There she is.
Wait!
That was not good.
Ah!
Get off of me!
Where is she?
Where'd she go?
This way.
My camera focus is not good.
Ah!
Oh, come on!
Shake off!
Guys, it might be it for us!
Oh, that was so bad.
That was so bad.
I'm scared!
I'm too scared!
Run away!
Oh my god, duh!
My willpower!
Oh, I think our thing used.
Oh my god, where is she?
Oh my god.
Don't go.
I can't get good shots.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, our mirror, our stone mirror used.
That's okay.
That's what it's.
Oh!
Ugh.
Dang it.
Lady, please.
Stand, stand, stand, stand, stand, stand.
Oh, my God.
Get off of me!
oh my gosh no i didn't get a good shot at all no please
madam i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm so it's so over guys
it's so over oh oh oh it's so over
she's so blurry and all my shots
please where are you oh my god run run i'm so dead it's so
over for us guys oh nice oh my gosh but not nice at the same
time my film is so slow it's so slow she's like tripping on
me We're hanging in there, one HP in a dream.
There we go.
Oh, please.
That was a good one.
Ah, no!
No!
Okay, let's try one more time.
So close.
This game, oh man, I...
It gets so...
Too little too late.
I know.
Gotta get back into it.
Oh!
Okay.
I think it was right before she started.
Okay, okay.
Hmm.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I know.
These games are not for the week.
These games are not for the week, you guys.
The lunar incense I also have for my willpower.
So let's try one more time.
Better checkpointing makes these games so much better.
Yeah, right.
Oh, you can skip too.
Just let you know.
All right, lady.
Come on, grandma.
Oh, that was...
Oh, I had my 90 fill mod.
I didn't realize.
No.
Oh!
Holy cow, lady!
Where are you?
No!
Don't touch me!
Get off of me!
You!
Yeah.
Oh, dang it, I think it just went down.
Oh.
Run!
Oh, don't please!
Get off of me!
I'm trapped in the corner.
Lock on.
She probably should have waited for her to get a little bit
closer.
Never mind!
Yeah!
Please, please, please, please, please!
Nice!
Why is this so much different?
Then last time, my film, please.
Oh, no, she healed again.
No, no, no.
Where'd she go?
This is where it gets tricky, though.
You!
Oh, I don't think I got her at all.
Oh, I did.
Barely, I think.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Steps up.
we're dodging and we're running and we're we're playing oh
my god yeah yeah come on lady oh shoot my camera got all
messed up i should probably lock on more ah dang it no get
off of me i'll heal
It's so scary.
Nope, run.
Nice.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
Oh no, I tried to do my special.
I didn't have enough willpower.
No!
Now, please leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Let's take a picture there.
Get her off of me.
Get off of me.
Stop tripping.
Lady.
Grandma.
She like falls on top of me.
She's so obsessed with me.
Photos are so scary.
Oh.
Oh, dang it.
No!
Get off of me.
We're almost there.
Oh, that was a good one!
That was a good one!
What's funny is this lady?
Oh, shoot.
She's not even, like, my favorite ghost in this game.
Did I get her?
No.
So close.
When I... She... Oh!
No!
You!
Now you!
Ah!
We were so close!
No!
Oh my god, I should have taken the shot!
We were so close!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Get off of me, please.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, she's hacking.
Only I'm allowed to heal.
You're a ghost.
You're not allowed to heal.
Only I'm allowed to heal.
Oh, shoot.
I have no more film.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Wait.
There we go.
Um.
Wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
Sorry.
please, Lairdy.
I'm trapped in this tiny house with you.
Oh.
Ah!
We're trying to finish her.
I'm trying!
Let's just...
Oh.
Anything.
Let's just do anything.
Oh, shoot.
Lady.
Lady, where are you?
There you are.
And...
Oh.
No.
Where is I just want to take you out?
that should be it oh my god yeah stinking lady yeah stinking
lady oh there was film in there yeah stinking lady yeah we
got that twin gizzo key left looks like the left half of the
gizzo statue when the twin pieces are brought together the
can be opened obtained the first key and i think that's
where we'll leave it for now just one more just one more key
oh oh meo take a breather me too lady in the box what were
you doing in there anyway doing her metal gear cosplay maybe
you guys don't forget if you thought this was stressful and
fine if you're interested in a challenge of taking becoming
your best photographer uh remember check it out on steam you
can wish list the game if you're still thinking about it but
please keep fatal frame in your thoughts because this series
is so great and i hope it i want it to continue on and on
and on and on And thank you again, Koei Tecmo, for
sponsoring me for today.
But I would have played the game anyway.
I would have played it anyway, but...
Yeah, use the link in the description or the one in the
pinned comment.
I didn't even realize it was sponsored.
It was just a good stream.
I'm glad you think so.
I try to.
For sponsors, I typically like to pick things that I, you
know, would also want to, you know, play so so I can give
you a genuine real reaction and all that um best
sponsorships are the ones you are already going to play
exactly exactly so oh that sounds like my heartbeat right
now but thank you guys thank you thank you thank you um and
yeah thank you Vicky for letting me use your PC but no thank
you for scaring me with 6-7 because that was just just plain
rude feel better be here
i'm gonna go blow my nose i'm gonna go blow my nose and i
hope you guys have a great day have a great night and i'll
see you whoa whoa oh my goodness i forgot that this game oh
can be played with not a controller um yeah
you have a good day have a good night see you later bye bye
oh my god i'm going through like the photos i took
so scary some of them are just like oh some of them are so
scary some of them look like realistic you know tell
what's going on some of them are so gross
nasty okay bye